Alright. So, what do you think?
>> Well I'm actually pulling out a piece of paper
>> To measure things on the screen?
>> You know, because my screen is actually flat on the ground or
flat on the table. So, it looks like e and f are closest.
>> Yeah, though I think we probably should
be willing to accept ef, df, or bg.
>> No.
>> Because they're all really similar.
>> E and f is close, b and g is
close. But d and f is actually pretty, is clearly
farther than the rest of them. Proved by.
>> D and. Really? because it looks like an equilateral triangle to me.
>> Maybe it is, actually. I take it
all back. Yeah, actually you're right. You're right.
It's the angle. Well actually d and f I think are closer than e and f.
>> Alright. Good! So that yeah. So the, so the, I would
say that any of those, any of those would be fine next.
>> Mm-hm. And, I think interestingly won't change the answer, in the end.
>> In the end. Yeah. So let's let's continue
with this process now that the quiz explanation is done.